when I was a student in fact when I was
at high school we had to do analytical
chemistry trying to identify different
ions like bromide iodide chloride and we
did all sorts of tests so I thought it'd
be quite fun to get Sam to do one of
these tests these tests look really
quite pretty then when I was a schoolboy
I found them really tedious it involves
adding silver nitrate to the solutions
and you get to precipitate when you add
the silver nitrate you get silver ions
in the solution which also contains
nitrate because you put in silver
nitrate but also chloride or bromide or
iodide ions the silver halides are very
insoluble so when the silver and the
halide ions meet they form a solid and
precipitate so there is quite a nice
reaction and you get a precipitate of
different colors depending which halogen
you use so as a test although I didn't
mention this to Sam she decided she
would use fluoride as well that's all
for halogens even get easily astatine
and the new one tennyson aren't really
available to do lab experiments silver
ions with fluoride was a bit
disappointing silver fluoride is
reasonably soluble in water so you don't
form a precipitate with silver chloride
you get a fairly white precipitate and
these precipitation reactions take place
incredibly fast much faster than your
eye can follow this is not something
that gradually develops one minutes it's
clear the next minute silver bromide is
pale yellow
and silver iodide is rather more yellow
now what am i telling you about these
compounds and the reason is that these
silver halides have been technologically
very important particularly silver
bromide because silver bromide was the
material that was used for old-fashioned
photographic film nowadays everybody
takes digital pictures but until really
quite recently most photographs were
taken on film and the film has a layer
of silver bromide crystals very small
ones and the amazing thing about silver
bromide crystals is that when they
absorb light they are dissociated so you
get silver metal formed you don't get
very much silver metal formed but then
when you put it into developing solution
that tiny piece of silver acts as a
catalyst and bigger particles grow to
give you the black color and black and
white film I hope one day we will be
able to show you in the darkroom
the chemistry of film but this compound
that sitting in the test tube is the
basis of all photographic film there is
one quite funny question which people
sometimes ask which is what is the color
of unexposed photographic film that is
film which has not been exposed to light
because if you want to know the color of
something you have to shine light on it
and if you shine light on it the film
has been exposed so nobody really knows
what the color of unexposed film is and
silver iodide crystals have a really
unexpected application which is to make
rain in the sky there is a lot of water
vapour and the water vapor can condense
to form clouds and the clouds produce
rain the problem is that water vapour
has to be cooled to a very low
temperature
before it will spontaneously form
crystals of ice but if there are tiny
particles in the air this acts as a
nucleus and the water droplets or ice
particles can form random shortly after
the Second World War about 70 years ago
it was sadly realized that the structure
of the crystals of silver iodide have
the same sort of spacing of the atoms as
in crystals of ice so people had the
idea of injecting very fine powders of
silver iodide into the air where clouds
were forming to make them form thicker
clouds and therefore to rain and it
works but nobody quite knows how and
most recently people have done
experiments and show that ice doesn't
form in the way that people thought and
so the spacing of the atoms on the
silver iodide is not the relevant
property that it still seems to work and
so in many countries now people use
silver iodide for seeding clouds there
are two reasons for seeding clouds one
reason is to make it rain to make your
plants grow better the other reason is
to get the clouds to start producing
rain before a real storm starts if you
don't see the clouds then they build up
and up and up and then suddenly start
producing large hailstones
which can cause enormous damage smashing
buildings denting cars and so on so
silver iodide can reduce or people
believe that it can reduce the force of
the storm and cause less damage
underneath it's paper up to one side
yeah in fact before we do that I want to
take a selfie with it this is me and the
first paper to describe like photos
properly you like in their goat yep they
range in
right depending on what the scene is its
artistic value from around 10,000 pounds
to the most expensive print in this box
is being valued at half a million pounds
for one photograph half a million pounds